the deal is done the month-long saga of
who will own twitter appears over
in one of the largest and most unusual
tech acquisitions ever the board of
directors at twitter unanimously agreed
to sell the social media company to elon
musk for 44 billion dollars
up until the deal was announced there
was doubt on wall street that musk could
cobble together the financing needed but
he did
musk helped pay for the deal with 25
25.5 billion dollars in debt financing
by a group of banks led by morgan
stanley in a press release announcing
the deal musk talked about improving the
platform by getting rid of automated
spam accounts and making its algorithms
open to the public and authenticating
all users
but for musk buying twitter is about
free speech or at least his version of
it potentially ending twitter's current
content moderation or stopping
de-platforming of users who break the
rules
elon musk is not buying twitter for
financial reasons although he thinks he
can make some money on it
he's buying it for ideological reasons
and i think that's the really important
part in all this
and that's ultimately what's scary
with musk in control they fear a return
to the unruly spread of disinformation
on the platform so is today a good day
or bad day for twitter users
that is probably the most important
question here um and i think it's also
the question that's going to be hardest
to answer i think that if he undoes a
lot of the work that has been done
trying to protect against sort of
normatively bad speech such as
misinformation and especially hate
speech that's going to be a bad day for
for twitter users um but you know
there's a chance that he takes over
and doesn't sort of have quite a
sweeping of a reform agenda as he's as
he's put forth
in over the last couple of weeks
it's been a tumultuous month for twitter
that saw musk take a nine percent stake
in the company making him its largest
shareholder he was then offered a seat
on the board of directors only to have
it abruptly revoked followed by his cash
offer to buy the entire company all
within the last few weeks
ultimately elon musk got what he wanted
to not only be a twitter user but to
also be its owner
gabriel rosando al jazeera new york